in terms of the structure of the brain
again this may be going into speculation
land i hope you
go along with me is uh
okay so the brain seems to be
intelligent
and our ai systems aren't very currently
so where do you think intelligence
arises in the brain
like what what is it about the brain so
if you mean where location wise it's no
single spot it would be equivalent to
asking
i'm looking at new york city
where is the economy the answer is you
can't point to anywhere the economy is
all about the interaction of
all of the pieces and parts of the city
and that's what you know intelligence
whatever we mean by that in the brain is
interacting from
everything going on at once in terms of
a structure so we look humans are much
smarter than
fish maybe not dolphins but
dolphins are mammals right but i assert
that what we mean by smarter has to do
with live wiring so
so what we mean when we say oh we're
smart is oh you can figure out a new
thing and figure out a new pathway to
get where we need to go
and that's because fish are essentially
coming to the table with you know okay
here's the hardware
go swim mate eat but we
have the capacity to say okay look i'm
gonna absorb oh oh but you know i saw
someone else do this thing and
and i read once that you could do this
other thing and so on so do you think
there's
is there something i know these are
mysteries but
like architecturally speaking what
feature of the brain
of uh of the live wire aspect of it
that is really useful for intelligence
so like is it the ability of
neurons to reconnect like
is there something is there any lessons
about the human brain you
think might be inspiring for us
and to take into the artificial
into the machine learning world yeah
i'm actually just trying to write some
up on this now called you know if you
want to build a robot
start with the stomach and what i mean
by that what i mean by that is
a robot has to care it has to have
hunger it has to care about surviving
that kind of thing here's an example so
the penultimate chapter in my book
um i titled the the wolf in the mars
rover and
i just look at this simple comparison of
you look at a wolf
it gets its leg caught in a trap what
does it do it gnaws
its leg off and then it figures out how
to walk on three legs
no problem now the mars rover curiosity
got its front wheel stuck
in some martian soil and it died
this project that cost billions of
dollars
died because guys wheels wouldn't it be
terrific if we could build a robot
that chewed off its front wheel and
figured out how to operate with a
slightly different body plan
that's the kind of thing that we want to
be able to build and to get there
what we need the whole reason the wolf
is able to do that is because
its motor and somatosensory systems are
live wired so it says oh you know what
turns out i've got a body plan that's
different than what i thought a few
minutes ago
but i i have a yen to survive
and i care about relevance which in this
case is getting to food getting back to
my pack and so on
so i'm just going to figure out how to
operate with this oh oops that didn't
work
oh okay i'm kind of getting it to work
but the mars rover doesn't do that it
just says oh geez i was pre-programmed
to have four wheels now i have three i'm
screwed
yeah you know i i don't know if you're
familiar with a philosopher named
ernest becker he wrote a book called
denial of death
and there's a few psychologists sheldon
salmon i think he i just
spoke with him on his podcast um who
developed
terror management theory which is uh
like ernest becker is a philosopher that
basically said that
uh mortality fear of mortality is at the
core of it yeah
and so i i don't know if it sounds
compelling as an idea
that we're all i mean that all of the
civilization we've constructed
is based on this but it's i'm familiar
with his work
here's what i think i think that yes
fundamentally
this desire to survive is at the core of
it i would agree with that
but but how that expresses itself in
your life
ends up being very different the reason
you do what you do
is i mean you could list the 100 reasons
why you chose to write your tweet this
way in that way
and it really has nothing to do with the
survival part it has to do with you know
trying to impress fellow humans and
surprise them and say something
yeah so many things built on top of each
other it's fascinating to think that
in artificial intelligence systems we
want to be able to somehow
engineer this drive for survival for
immortality i mean because us humans
we're not just
it's about survival we're aware of the
fact that we're going to die
which is a very kind of where we're like
space time
by the way aren't all right confucius
said
uh he said each person
has two lives the second one begins when
you realize that you have just one
yeah but but most people it takes a long
time for most people to get there
i mean you could argue this kind of 40
thing which erzbecker
argues is they it's they
they actually figured it out early on
and the terror they felt was like the
reason
it's been suppressed and the the reason
most people when i ask them about
whether they're afraid of death they
basically say no
they basically say like um i'm afraid i
won't get
like submit the paper before i die like
they kind of see they see death as a
kind of uh
inconvenient deadline for a particular
set of
like a book you're writing yeah it's as
opposed to like
what the hell this thing ends this like
any moment like most people as if i have
encountered do not meditate on the idea
that like
right now you could die like right now
like it it's like it in in the next five
minutes
it could be all over and you know
meditate on that idea
i think that somehow brings you closer
to like
the core of the motivations and the core
of the human
cognition condition but like i said it
is not
yeah there's so many things on top of it
but it is interesting i mean
as the ancient poet said uh death
whispers at my ear
live for i come so it's
it is certainly motivating when we think
about that
okay i've got some deadline i don't know
exactly what it is but i better make
stuff
happen it is motivating but i don't
think uh i mean i know for just
speaking for me personally that's not
what motivates me day to day it's
instead
oh i want to get this you know
program up and running before this or i
want to make sure my co-author isn't mad
at me because i haven't gotten this in
there i don't want to miss this grant
deadline or
you know whatever the thing is yeah it's
too it's too distant in a sense
nevertheless it is good to reconnect but
for the ai systems
none of that is there uh like a neural
network
does not fear it's mortality uh and that
that seems to be somehow fundamentally
missing the point
it's i think that's missing the point
but i wonder it's an interesting
speculation about whether you can build
an ai system that is much closer to
being a human
without the mortality and survival piece
but just the thing of
relevance just i care about this versus
that right now if you have a robot roll
into the room
it's going to be frozen because it
doesn't have any reason to go there
versus there it doesn't have any
particular
set of things about
this is how i should navigate my next
move because i want
something yeah there's a that's the
thing about humans
is they seem to generate goals they're
like
you said live wired i mean it it's very
flexible in terms of the goals and
creative in terms of the goals you
generate when we enter a room
you show up to a party without a goal
usually
and then you figure it out a lot yes but
this goes back to the question about
free will which is when i walk into the
party
if you rewound it 10 000 times would i
go
and talk to that couple over there
versus that person like
i might do this exact same thing every
time because i've got some goal stack
and i think okay well at this party i
really want to meet
these kind of people or i feel awkward
or whatever you know whatever my goals
are
you